です。
めっちゃ減らします。
ありがとうございます。
いえいえ。いやあ。
はい。
あ、それこそ僕のYouTube
とかの映像も公開前に自称ミニマリストして
[笑い]
じゃあそのまま立ち位置そのまま大丈夫なので今こっちを向いてもらって
します。
で、ま、スーツとかしっくりしたものがなんか上の
あ、行くです。
はい。こっちにちょっとちょっと待たけ。
はい。ということでスーツもですね、最近はもうジャケットとかで来てるので上下セットのやつって
はい。
ほぼ着なくなっちゃって
お客さん先に行く時に来ますかって言って、ま、着るよなっていうのが
1着あればいい出た。
減らしました。
無理です。
めっちゃ減らします。
ありがとうございます。
いえいえ。いやあ。
うん。あの、記録残していたもっていうあれですもんね。
性使わずになんか
字幕だけです。
字幕ですもんね。
はい。よいしょ。
すごいすごいって。
ま、それこそ僕のYouTube
とかの映像も公開前にはチェックはしていただくんですけど。はい。
あ、そうなんですね。
これダウンして一部映像使った。
ああ
あ、ちょうど。
あ、
次は2
階のクローゼット横にある難度の整理をしていきます。どれを手放すか今からどんどんどんどん見直していきます。
えっと、またこれだけのものが出ました。
ここからいるものといらないものの選別を
していきます。
こちらは手放すものです。
ちゃんは赤ちゃんを怪しているのでしょうか?怪してよ。
うん。
今夜の9時です。旦那さんと一緒に
キッチンにあった水屋ダンスと
水やダンスと同じぐらいの大きさの
カウンターを運び出しました。
こんばま。いい持ってるから。ああ、
ちょっと上にあげれば大丈夫だね。
うん。
ああ、もうちょっとこれ
うん
。
はい。
すごい確かに。そして殻になった。ここも撮影
されてますね。あ、和室のやつ足してないですからね。
の入上談にまで天井まであったトイレット
ペーパーやマスクなど紙すっきり片付いて
います。
この水やの冗談のクローゼットでしたが、今はこちらにちょっとタンスが置いてある後が絨毯についていますが、はもう全て何も入ってきません。
もったいないなと思いますが、
こちらにはもうは一切入っておりません。
入っているのは私のスーツケース。こちら
。こちらもお客様布団など全て処分しまし
た。こちらもパンパンパンに布団が入って
いたんですが、今
最後の箱です。
何がなくなったの?
時計。
時計?
どういう時計?
なんでゴミ箱の中分かるの?
音が鳴ってるわけ。
ねえ。あ、ここになんでここれ捨てるの?自分で吸ってたじゃないの?
これなの?入れてないもん。これ入れてないし。これも俺入れてないし。
どれ?どういう時計?
この時計。入ろ。
ということで、ちょっとそうですね、もう夜の
7時過ぎですけども、もう長時間
時間以上片付きました。お疲れだと思うので、
ありがとうございます。
一旦ご飯休憩で
あたかも僕が振るまってるから、あの、モてなしていただいてるの僕なので、あの、僕のためにこのサーモンづし、
[笑い]
サーモンです。塩食べてください。
ありがとうございます。
こっちもあ、全部あのバサにしたんで。
あ、これは物
ああ、全物やつ。しかもなんか僕あのお寿司サ抜きでしか食べないから全部錆び抜きにしていた。
さっきお酒飲むんですか?みたいな話があったと思うんですけど、僕本当に全然お酒飲まなくて。うんうん。いいことです。
ま、お酒飲まなくてもいいけど、サーモン食べれないのが作れてます。
僕割り絶対食うの入る。
へえ。そうなんです。ま、結構僕ももう今
日ぐらい毎日この形でやってんですよ。
でもため取りですか
ね。
だから1日8時間けて
で撮影終わった後日とか今回
日終わったらすぐ大阪で翌日から始まるんで
撮影移動撮影なんかま、
YouTube
の企画ではあるんですけどやってることは本当にちょっと人そうです。
本当そう
ね。なので
幸せをもたらす感じですね。
[笑い]
そうですね。でも
はい。
ありがたいことに
うん。
絶対特積んでる感じだよね。
うん。第
1任者だからね。やってるんですか?
えっと、僕の活動自体
11年前からやって。
すごい。
うん。な
んでやろうと思ったんです?あ
あ、ちょ、ちょっと待って。
こっからインカメでカメラ回してちょうどすいません。ありがとうございます。
[笑い]
年前にミニマリストなんて言葉あった?
ないよね。あ
あ、ちょうどう
そうすね。
何きっかけで始めたんですか?て聞かれたのでカメラ回して
はい。ちょっと引き続きお寿司食べてるんで、
えっとそうですね。ま、まずさっき言った
11年前は
うん。
確かにミニマリストって言葉はまだえっと流行語になる手前でした。
2015年に流行後に1回なってて
そうなんですね。
そうなんだ。
ちょうどその12年前から僕
実践してて
うん。
すごい
先先打ってる
そうすね。なんか流行ヌιαぬとりは
1人暮らしをした。
やっぱ実家暮らしのフリーターだったんで、
ま、少ない収年で1
人暮らしをするって時にやっぱ物の少ない方が、ま、小さな家に住めるし、うん。
ま、僕最初の言ってるぐらいしも家賃
1万9000円とかの、
ま、ちっちゃい6
畳みたいなとこでうん。うん。
生活したんすけど、ま、物が少なかったそこでも全然広いし
うん。
ミに引っ越セルチってところから減らし始めてったら、
ま、そこで一応なんすかね、一応ミニマリストミニマリズムって、ま、アメリカ発症海外から逆ユニみたいな感じなんですけどうん。ま、なんかするけど。うん。
で、ま、だから一応なんかミニマリズムって考え方はすでにあったんだけど、なんかちょうど僕が実践してで、なんかそのもの減らしたなんかこういうもの減らしましたとかこういう生活してますってのも本当趣味で書いてたら
うん。
なんかそのまま流行になるくらいなんか勢いがうん。
ま、ちょうど多分東日本大震災とかとかぶってて、ま、震災でそれこそ
あの、被災された方々が物減らし始めて物減らそうみたいな流れ。
ああ。ああ。
あった中で、
ま、そっから火がついて
うん。
で、
もうそうっすね、カレ
11年
経ちましたね。
続けれるってすごいですよね。
うん。
そうですね。俺が仕事になるとも思ってなかったですけど、なんか開けちゃうかなって思うけど。開けない。
そうですね。なんか僕ミりつと渋いんだけど、意外とやることはコロコロ変わって
うん。
最初はブログだったんですね。
ブログを書き始めてで、それが籍化されてで、ブログ時代になんか暴れるこの今自分が着てるシャツとかそうなんですけど、ま、デブで出かける出かけられるバックレスっていうものとか
ありがとうございます。
ま、こういったものは一応ブロガー時代から
なんか、ま、YouTuber
さんが結構今暴れでやってるイメージあると思うんですけど、なんか僕は意外と
YouTube
やる前からブログ時代からその手ブ財布っていうスマホのスマホ裏に貼り付ける財布があって、それを作ったのが
2018とかかな。7
年前とかなんですけど。
買いたい。[笑い]
どこで書えるんですか?
あ、是ひ概要欄の
isJPという
はい。
オンラインでも買いますし、ま、東京とかだとあの中メ黒の津店さんとか店頭にもある。
ええ、すごい。是ひ買います。
ていうので元々僕フリーター自体にアパレルじゃないとアウトレットモールあのもう何%
オフとかのシールがある
バイトででスマホケースのお店がアパレルの中にあってそこでバイトしてたんですけど
その時にもう無限にスマホケースとか
なんかそういうまさに手帳型ケースとか色々うん
見てたからあこういうデザインのがあれば
なんか手ブで財布なしでも出かけられるに言ってずっと頭にあったから
ううん。
なんかそのプリーター時代のバイト経験とかが今の商品開発にすごい生きてますね。
ああ、
商品発してるんですよね。そういう服とか。
そうなんですよ。
次だよね。
服と
パンツですか?
パンツはちょっと違うやつなんですけど。でもそうすね。
上着ですよね。
上着も色々作ってますね。エコバッグとか財布とかもうなんならメガネとかも
え、すげえすごい
デザイン監修してますしとか。
ま、財布地下に色々うん。
パンツもですね。
現金って持ってるんですか?そ、現金
現金持ってないようなイメージがすごくあるんですよ。
現金ってでも使う時もちょっとあるかな。
おするですか?
これとスマホ裏に貼り付けるこれカードケース最近結構
iPhoneとか磁
ああすごいね。ちょっと
旅行に行く時はそういうのがいいね。
ここに
うん。
はい。はい。
カード、えっと、あ、ここにカード、カードと免許ですね。
免許症と
で、あとちょっとこれですね、これおったお札だけ入れて。
うん。うん。うん。うん。うん。うん。
うん。
これでこれでいい。
はい。
すご。
1個
スマホのアイコンは
はい。
え、もう少ない。ミニマン、ミニマン。あ
あ、そうですね。今ちょっとスマホで撮影してるんですけど、ちょっと画像貼っとくんですけど。
[笑い]
はい。
もう大変に気っちゃってるんですけど、私なんか
あ、ホーム画面の中ですね。
そう、ミニマリストの形ってアイコンもですよ。
アイコンも
うん。
ミニマムなのかなと思っ
でもはい。そういう人多いすし、もう僕こんな感じであの、ちょっと店ね、今スマホしてたんですけど、り見せますって、ま、
[笑い]
こんな感じで実はめっちゃもうホーム画面もすっきりさしてすっきりなんですね。
ぐちゃぐちゃできる男だね。
でも実際そうでお家が散らかってる人は財布の中、カの中、スマホの中全部散らかった。
[笑い]
レシートとかがいっぱいあるやつですか?
あ、
そう。レシートレシーがある。
パソコンもいっぱいぐちゃぐちゃだね。
そう。
パソコンのデスクトップがとかこれって要は死者選択の能力なんで、ま、だから物減らすことっていうのは僕資の訓練と言ってるんですけど、ま、家が片付けられるようになるとそっからさっき言った財布だったりスマホの中ップの中とかもちゃんと
片られるようになりますね。
うん。
今日もそんなに寒いような気が寒い時はどうしてるんです?その身軽じゃないですか?身軽なのでダウンとかやっぱりこうで期待筋トレしてるっていうのと僕も毎日絶対サの入るんですよ。
あ、で、
水風呂入んだ。
会社めっちゃいいと思います。
僕も水ブロは入りました。
合ってるね。
コートはえっとコートはなくて、えっと、一応ダウンベスト。
あ、ダウンベスト。
ダウンベスト、
ダウンベスト買えばいいんだ。
大事にしますよ、僕。もう
今日一応しさんが来るからって言ってみんなドレスコード
[笑い]
全員黒いもんな。ちょっと
わざとなんですよ、これ。
ちょっと
わざとなんですね。
わざとでもでもでも普段私結構来るばっかりなんで東京でしようね。
少々お待ちください。ちょっとコメントは
とあるとある関係で黒起きてるんでつも
すごい僕の目の前これ全員来るです。
[笑い]
すごい光景が黒の秘密決者みたいな怪しい基
はい。
みんな渋さん目指して頑張ろうって。
今日みんな黒来てくださん
だと今いいんかもしれてませんね。
へえ。そうですね。
なんかちょっとさっきのなんかなんか片付け企画へ人助けしてみたいともう
回なんか振ってもらえると嬉しいです。得意です。エンディで頑張ってね。
[笑い]
本当人です。
そうですね。
シずさんの仕事はゆる人助け
チック。チックじゃない。人助けです。
確かに。なんか僕実は今片付けの企画をもう
50日毎日取るみたいな撮ってて。
で、今ちょうど、えっと、30日
うん。うん。うん。
で、えっと、ちょ、30
日目なんですけどうん。
そうすね。なんか、なんか、ま、
YouTuber
なんだけど、ま、片付け業者的ななんか
ことやってる。
うん。業者っぽい。ちょっと、
そうですね。だからね、こう
YouTube企画ではあるんですけど
うん。
ありがたい。ありがたい。
みんな人ってあれですか?人生が変わりましたみたいな人言ったんですか?
あ、もうめっちゃ言われますよ。
物を捨てるのは断捨りちゃうんですか?
ちょっとそれでなすごいなんかうん。
でも何年後かに
幸せになれる
すごい
綺麗になると心がお金が全然まらなかったけど物を減らしたらお金がすごい溜まるようになった。
何年かに再開してこうなりましたみたいな。
あ、ありそうでも
あ、めっちゃあります。
さっきなんかそのミニマリスト仕長いですないですかこと言われてさっきブログだったりって話をして
で今YouTubeやったりとか
YouTube
の中でも元々僕の結構私生活を中心に安心したんけどさ結構語って企画をこの
2年でやり始めて
うん
でもう古い人は2
年前からやってるんですけど最近なんかあの家賃まとめ払いしましたみたいな
あ
人とかでもずっと家計が
ずっと家計が
応してたけど
あそうですしたりと
才能するレベルで家が火の車だったんだけど物減らしてからもう本当にお金使わなくなってでちもましたって人も
いるくらいなんで
幸せがやってくるってことなんですか?
うん。本当そうだよね。もう
ミニマリストイコール幸せが来るみたいな。
でもやっぱり根本的にじゃなんで物の減らしてるかってるそこなんですよね。
ま、幸せに行きたいからっていうのが物減らしてる理由で、
ま、今でこそミニマリストってもう生活の、
ま、そうですね、あの、生活スタイルの
つになったからなんか昔に比べてなんだろう。それこそ僕はあの流行語になった時とかってまだなんかこうステー変態みたいなちょっと
000的なこう床何にもない床にあぐなんか座然組んでちょっとこう、ま、怪しい人というかちょっとあの変わった人みたいな扱いされてたんですけどうん。
本当にそうでしたもん。
うん。11
年前とかはだからミニマリスト渋時も何それ?笑みたいな。
今本当そうでした。ミやってなのになんかそう今もう売名とか言ますからね。
あんだけ馬鹿にされてたのに。ま、そうですね。ま、そんなもんだと思うんですけど。でもそういう扱いでした。やっぱり
っていうのでまだからだからそうなんですよね。
やっぱり物減らすとそういう風にお金が溜まるとか
探し物なくし物しなくていいから頑張ろう私ての
もう神みたいなそんなそういう人って何人いるんですか?何ていうか
[笑い]
結構人いっぱいいるじゃないですか?いっぱいいるじゃないですか?
確かにな
そういうそういう本を書いたりなんかそういうやったログとかや
YouTubeとかやってもしさんは大事
そうだけどやっぱりいると思うんですよ何人かいるんかなと思ってる
はい。真似てやってることにだから
断捨りとどっちが早いんですか?ミニマリストリってこと?
断捨りのが早いです。
あ、順番で言ったら
断捨あとこまり先生
あ、先生、
あの時めくのがなので、えっと、断捨りが
2005年に流行になってて、
で、こんまり先生の形は200年
先生なんか知らない。知らない。
夢有夢有夢。アメリカ海外でも有名。
とりあえずほ、あの、どういう
ときめくと解きめくと解きめかないものかと解めくそれは聞いたことある。それせないていう。
あ、そうです。そうです。
あの、もう金沼とかにいちいち出たんで、もしかすると見たことあるかも。あの、黒髪の長い日本かなかって
全然顔変わってないもんね。
そう、ヤ和名シみたいな方がいいで、ま、要ではあえと断捨りが
2005年で201年にこまり先生で
2015年にミニマリストみたいな形じゃ
5年収ぐらいになんか
片付けの概念かブームになってる人何がいですかね。
だって断捨てるだけだけどミニマリストはもその生活を続けるから続けるってこと。
うん。
ああ、そうすね。なんかダイフスタイルですね。まさにうん。
あの、今回すごく応募がたくさん見たと思うんですけど。
はい。
あの、私の家に
あの、来ていただけるっていうなんか決め手とかあったんです。
[笑い]
ああ。はい。決め手ありまして。
多分それが番てなくて様が来てくださるってもう大騒ぎで。
うん。ああ。はい。
で、私てうん。
私に言わなかったらすごい怒るでしょ。てから怒る怒るて。
なんであん時言ってくれなかったのって怒る。
へえ。
大興奮だったもんね。
面談も
あのすごく挙動不審だったと思うんです。
[笑い]
YouTube
の冒頭に面談の映像をちょっと使わせていただくので出てると思うんですけど。
いつも今日でおたね。
うん。
はい。決め手はもうありますね。
面白い。
あ、どういうことだ。きたいです。ま、基本的には僕
1ベースで選んでないと。
ま、物量ともちろんやっぱり企画ではあるから、ま、ちょっとビフォーアフターが大きい方がいいので、そ、物量が多い人は優先していってはいるんですけど、
ま、それだけではなくてやっぱり話してみての直感だったり人柄とか教えて、
ま、なんだかんだで
引き出し多そうですね。そうね。[笑い]
なんだかんだで1日8時間とかそれを23
時連続とかで見なわけだから、
ま、相性が話ってみて相性悪かったらやっぱりお互いストレスだと思う。そう。
ま、大体って人を見てるっていうのが1
番で
良かったね。
その上にめられた。
おめでとう。
ま、その上でも1
番の聞きめてだったのやっぱりあの備蓄が多い人
良かったじゃん。[拍手]
無駄にぶち無駄にね、いっぱい買い込んで
多いのは
捨てる対象になるんじゃないんですか?
そうですね。ま、持ちすぎもちろんある。あの必要なものだしあっていいんですけど、ま、適量ってものがあるというか、ま、株不足なく揃えるってのはやっぱ大事ですよね。
やっぱりその、ま、蓄防災って、ま、別に数年に
1回もだから[笑い]
逆が良かったのね。それが
それが良かったです。良かった。だっていないですもんね。
なかなか1
年単位で持ってるとかは
おかしい。
なかなかないし。しかもルさんご自身がその
YouTube
で防災の発信してるなのにチャンネル名ミニマルライフなんか真逆ちょっとおかしさを
[笑い]
見つけてしまったんですね。
ま、それは多分なんかたまたまあげたね防の動画がバズってしまって自分が行きたい方向性と真逆のものがちょっと
[笑い]
その葛藤みたいな
どういう人なのかって興味を示されたというか
うんかったね
ていうとこだしま僕もですねあの本当にあの防災用に取ってますっていうので捨てない人めっちゃ多いんですよ
でもそういう人に借りってなんか意外と
あルさんの場合ちょっと違うんですけど一般
的になんか捨てられない人がいる防災って結構そもそも例えば防災カが作られてなくてもう防災アイテムが入れあっちこっちになってするから
ちゃんとまとまってない整理されてないとかそもそもなんか賞味期限が切れてるとかま期限が切れてるとめ込みやすい感じなんだ
とかえっと逃げ道にないとか
今回あのウルさんの場合も玄関になったからまさに逃げ道のとこにちゃんと備えてるっていうところ
うんと
えいそれはねかなり防災意思がめちゃくちゃ高
うん。
あの、大丈夫なんですけど、他の人が言う防災ってなんか捨てない理由として使ってて、
僕セ防災って呼んでるんですよ。防
そう、例えば防災アイテムなのに押入れのなんかすごい奥の方にあって取り出せないとか
結構でもいらっしゃって。
あ、そうなん。結構います、本当に。ま、だからそういう人はいっぱいいるんですけど、なんかここまで
1年分取ってます。
で、しかももうそれがちゃんと明確に理由があって、なんかもう避難所に行きたくないからとかなんか唱えておかないと不安でとか、またさっきプレッパーっていう言葉使ったんですけど、海外とかではそういう考えがあって
うん。うん。
その世界競争とか何かあった時に備えて、ま、サバイバルで生き延、ま、サバイバリストなんて言ったりする。
すごいなんかだんだんスケールが多く意思が強い、すごい素敵な女性な感じになっちゃってる。
[笑い]
ま、そういう考え方もあったりするので
うん。
なんかそういう意味ではこうミニマリストとちょっと真逆のところ行ってる側面もある。確かに
部分部分で見ると減らせてるところもあるんだけどこと備蓄においてはすごいちょっと多いし
僕が今まで語ったことはないパターンだったで
若干多いなって思ったけどでもすごい行ってくるから
YouTube
見てると美自分は少ないんじゃないかって思うんですよね。
もなんか
ま、色々な考え方があるけどでもまあマリストの方が多いっていう
のがコメントいただいたからうん。
し、特にあの、ま、防災のためにも持っとくて大事なんですけど、特に日本においてはやっぱ自信が多かったりするから、
それこそあの阪神代とかの
番のシーンって実はあの建物そのものの崩壊よりもその例えばタスが倒れていって無念を直撃したとか
そういっていうシーンが多かったりしてなんから物に殺されてるって僕よく結構あの冗談じゃなく僕
YouTube
で結構よく物に殺されるって表現してるんです
うん。
あれは例えば枕元になんかあの棚とか置いてて寝てる間にタスが倒れてきて直撃してとかあとか僕の片企画はなんか途中で画病踏んでみたい人とかま結構本当にあと思ってるとそういう風に自信が来たことによって食器が割れてその破片で怪我がしたとかうん。っ
ていう人が多い。ま、特に日本は地震も多いし島国であのまねそうですね。うん。
その土地が土地が狭いので、あの、なおさらやっぱりちゃんと空間作っておかないと物によって逃げ道が塞がれるとか怪我するとか
物を減すことが命が守ることに繋がるよって僕よく言ってるんですけど。
うん。うん。
そのよく動画とかたまになんか見てるとお米
お米をお米屋さんみたいに持ってる人いません?なんかよくわからんけど。あ、
乳くまい。
前みたいなやつをもうわーってな部屋に
それって言ってなみたいな。
なんか虫が湧きそうにね。
うん。
そうです。そうです。虫がきそうみたいなと思うんですけどなんかみたいな
もやばいよね。うん。
そう。だから結局も必要なんだけどありすぎると管理がもに近づかないってこと。ま、
現実的に無理だよねって話。
あの、ま、さっきも一応
年保存とかそれに賞味切出さないようにってのは意識はしてると思うんですけど、ま、実際やっぱり備蓄が多いことによってそのね、玄関、もう玄関スペースが埋まってたりとか、
まだお家が広いからなんとかなってますけど。
そうです。意識高い
高い女子だと。
え、渋さんは備蓄はされてるんですか?
あ、防災物はちゃんとあるんですね。
あります。
防災カがあってヘルメットしたりラジオだったり、ま、懐中電と、ま、ランタンとか、ま、それこそ備蓄、
あの、ま、5日分は僕は
最低限やっていけるようにはお水とかもありますし、
消化機もなかったでした。
あ、消化機もありますね。何気に
何気にあります。なんか消化機はなんか入りに真っ白の消化機があって、なんかちょっとアート的できれるなと思って
うん。
なんかそうすね。ま、白い消化器はあったりするんですけど、ま、意外とあります。ヘルメット、折りのヘルメットとか。あ、うん。うん。
でも本当にもう玄関にちょこっと置けるくらいの
うん。うん。うん。うん。
もうコンパクトにも止まってますし実はえっと防災道具をそのえっと置けない防災道具置いてない人の理由聞くと
位はあの置くスペースがないっていう実は防災道具持ってない人は置くスペースがないから持ってないじゃない人が多くて意外とスペース取るんですよね。防災道具備蓄とかって。うんうん。
ま、だからこそ僕も物の減らしてで浮いたスペースにちゃんと防災道具となるといいですよって話は。
じゃあ、ちゃんと防災はされてるんだ
から、ま、実際そうすね、あの、ま、玄関だったりとかそういう場所に物を置けてるからこそ、ま、今まで物減らしてきてると思いますよ。僕
うん。そうですね。一応自称ミマリスト。
[笑い]
はい。ル笑い起きちゃう。笑い起きちゃうかね、これ。
うん。
うん。でもそう。
自称だからね。
自だ。[笑い]
ちゃんとルミニマルなのって
人ものフォロワーがフォローしていらっしゃいますから。
始めたのにね。それはすごいな。
そう。それ本当にすごいんですよ。この数字。
9ヶ月、あの、9ヶ月前で2700
人マジすごいです。
今のYouTube
って本当に登録者の見すじゃ。そうなんだ。
何よりも登録、ま、ぶっちゃけ今の、えっと、今
YouTube
見てる皆さん、えっと、僕のチャンネルのとこ下に多分登録者出てないと思います。
えっと、最近YouTube
アップデートがあって、
昔ってYouTubeの動画の下に
チャンネル名と登録者が出てましたよね、画面の下に。
うん。うん。あ、
今出てないんすよ、
これ。多分。
へえ。
ちょっと動画つれてるかわかんないんですけど、
今11月の19
日に撮ってて、多分このアップデート入ったのが
1週、1週間前とか
うん。
で、ま、要は何が言いたいかって言うと、今
YouTube
でも登録者を意識してないんですよ。大事にしてない。
あ、そうなんですね。
えっと、TikTokとかじゃあじゃ、
TikTokとかInstagram
の皆さんショート動画見てる時って
動画の中に登録者って出ないですよね。
うん。
ま、フォローボタンあるけど
YouTube
って再生してる画面の下にチャンネル名と何万人登録ってあるじゃないですか。
てことはYouTube
ってのは元々登録者をちゃんと、ま、その登録者にちゃんと価値があるっていう風に多分多いたと思うし
うん。
ま、やっぱりある程度チャンネル登録者がある動画ってのが分かればあ、この動画安心して見えるなってみてあったと思うんですよ。
でも今多分もうYouTube
ってだから登録者そんなに重要視してなくて
あの多分さ、今実際
YouTuberの間とかでも例えば
100万登録いるんだけど1
万再生しかもってないとか
逆にま登録だけど毎回
万再生されたみたいな。これどっちがつ高いかって言うと、ま、もちろん
万登録にもすごいそれまで頑張ってきた歴史ですよね。
ま、チャンネル登録ってそれまでの頑張ってた歴史の、ま、努力の送量だと思ってるんですけど
で再生回数直近の再生回数ってのは今の勢いみたいな風に捉えると多分今
YouTube
が意識してるのはもう登録者以上に、ま、ちゃんとそのチャンネルが再生されてるか
ああ、
再生回数と再生時間ですね。
うん。あの、僕今実はYouTube
公式にちょっとそういうアシスタントの方がついてるんですけど、ま、これ公表、その一般にちゃんと公表されてるんで言っちゃいけないこととかではなく
カットせず使うんですけど、
えっと、なんか、ま、普通に
数百万人いる人とかについてる人もいればついてない人もいるんですよ。
うん。
万人ぐらいの登録者で公式のアシスタントがついてて結構ちょいちょいイベント呼んでもらったりしてるんですけど
多分僕最登録者は
万人だからそんなめっちゃ追いしてないです。トップが何百万人いること考えると
でも多分
再生時間においては結構僕日本トップクラスの事故です。
番1話が長いですもんね。3時間とか1
本3時間とか
見ちゃう。
見ちゃうちゃう
ありがたいですね。
だから僕のなんか別に自慢してわけじゃないですけど、僕の
1体生って多分他のYouTubeの
YouTubeチャンネルの5
倍ぐらいの価値ちゃなんですよ。ああ、
えっと、一般的に
10分の動画あげると、ま、3分とか4
分再生されるんですけど、だから皆さん
10分の動画あげると大体34
分見てるんですけど、
ま、この動画結構と結構何気に結構すごいこと喋ってる気がするんですけど、
YouTuber
の人多分すごい散歩だと思うんですけど、僕
3時間の動画とか出すと、
えっと、1回24分ぐらい平均てます。
なんかみんな3
時間の動画をクリックするともう平均で
24分見てるっていう。
時間の動画とかになるともう僕なんか
30分とか見てみてるね。
ま、平均です。ま、最後までちゃんと通してみる人いれば離脱する人もいるんで、あくまで平均なんですけど。うん。
ま、だから僕一般的な
YouTube
チャンネルのえっとそうですね
6倍そうすね
6倍から
うん。8
倍ぐらい6、
ま、67
倍ぐらいは僕再生、再生時間が多いんですよね。
ああ、
だから、ま、現金な話をすると、あの、
[笑い]
YouTube
って動画の時間が長いほど広告いっぱい入るんですよね。
ああ、
だからよく言われてるのが多分
YouTube
再生回数いくらとか調べると大体
1再生0.2円から、ま、0.4
円とか出てくる。出てくるんですね。ネット上には。うん。
だ、僕はなんかもう全然それより来るみたいな感じだね。うん。
で、YouTube
って、ま、やっぱりなんかそのさ、さっきの話を戻すと
結構そういう、ま、もう登録者じゃなくて、ま、登録、再生時間とか回数とかそっちを結構重視してる気はします。重要してたら絶対チャンネルして、今登録者出てると思うんですけど。
うん。
だからなんか僕最近YouTube
見てて動画見てるとそのチャンネル名も出てこないし、
登録者も出てこないから、あ、これどんなチャンネルなんだろう。
いちいちなんかワンクリックしてホーム画面に行かないと確認できないからちょっとめんどくさいなと思うんですけど。うん。多
分なんかもうYouTubeはだからもう
いやでも多分YouTube
市場初めてのアップデートなんですよね。これ
へえ。そして人助けていう話に戻りましたね。してましたけども
[笑い]
声がいいから聞けるんだよね。
あ、ありがとうございます。
すいません。なんかやらしてこと言った。あ
[笑い]
あいないと。
あ、全然全然大丈夫です。ありがとうございます。
きやすい声なんだよね。
うん。
ああ。なんかむしろ僕なんか
学生の時とか自分の声が嫌すぎて
なんか声手術とか声変える方法癒し癒し癒される感じのあ、
ありがとうございます。でも本当にそれくらい自分の声コンプレックスでしたね。
いいこと言うじゃん。妹さん。
[笑い]
妹さんが
妹さんいいこと言う。
ありがとうございます。
そうですね。
だから、ま、ちょっと話は戻るんですけど、ま、ちょっとなんか人的なこと言っていたと思うんですけど、ま、
YouTube
の企画ではやってる人で、僕が多分続けてる理由ってこういう風にやっぱ感謝されるからっていうのが
1番
ああ、
大きいですね。なんか今までってよくも歩くなんですけどじゃミニマリストになる方法とか減らしましたみたいな感じでお家でカメラ置いてカメラの前に喋っちゃえば、ま、それなりに再生されて
あ、そうなんですね。
楽ではあります。だってわざわざ僕の
YouTube
でもこれ取るために、ま、今回福岡から、ま、そうですね、地方の方まで、ま、チューブ名古屋っていうの言ってもいいですかね?
なんかいいですか?名
古ちゃんだけじゃないってこと言ってて、
私じゃない。ちゃ、ワンちゃ、[笑い]
そうですね。ま、あとなので、えっと、ま、僕今あの、そうですね、全国飛び回りながら今回も、ま、名古屋まで来てるんですけどうん。
あの、そうですね、今回福岡から名古屋に来てるので、ま、やっぱりお家の、そうですね、お家の中にカメラ置いてポンで終わりじゃなくて
移動もあるし、
ま、今回も3日間1日8
時間もぶっ通して撮影してますし、
本動画出すのにめちゃくちゃ時間もかかって
うん。
時間もかかるし、あと編集者さんとかにもすごいお金が
あ、交通費とかもかんですよ。うん。でしょうね。
えっと、実は、ま、ここだけの話をすると
もうあの交通費と編集費とか入れると僕のこの片付動画
1本出すので最低30万かいます。
へえ。
はい。
だから僕この動画で30
万は稼がないとさ、赤字です。うん。
へえ。
やっぱり今ホテル台とかも高いし
うん。
ま、あと編集者さんもやっぱりもちろんもう何十材を編集してもらうから
ミニマムで30
万なんかちょっとなんか喉面白いことしない。
[笑い]
あ、なんかごめんなさい。
そういうことをなんかその立場かかってるから頑張ってるって話じゃなく
えっとすぐそういう方
そうねあのまちょっとその裏事情話した方面白いかなと思って入んでけど面白面白いです
でもなんかそうっすねそれが続いてるのはやっぱりま感謝されてるとか見てくれてる人がいっぱいいるからですね
そんだけみんなが求めてるんだよね
意外に捨てても後悔しないんですよね
名言
うん
本当そう
忘れてるんじゃない忘れるし
もう奥から出すから忘れてるや
しかないの。うん。
うん。だって本だってさ、何十年前のさ、栄光じゃん。の、過去の栄光にね、
[笑い]
そう、ちょっとね、過去の栄光ずっと思ってて見てなかったよね。
見てなかった。
久しぶりに見てね。
うん。もう
だから捨てれるんだ。親べもあるだし。だわ。
[笑い]
そうなんですよ。もう本当にみんなに捨てて公開したも本当に。
む、むしろ早く捨てなかったことを後悔してる。
うん。確かにこれ止まっとるですね。
思い出さないぐらい後悔がないの。
そう。捨てたものも覚えてないですよね。
覚えてないんです。
特に
うん。
なんか妹さんは結構なんかこう捨てのマインドが身ついてるというか。ま、い
はい。椅子そ渡しましたけどなんか言ってることが物減らした人の実態権な気がしました。
[笑い]
ああ。しました。
そうなんで最近ちょっと
うん。うん。
あの、食もなくなって断捨もなく
[笑い]
まあなんかそう
あとは体重を断した
[笑い]
はい。ま、体重もっていうとこもありますけど、
ま、でもだから僕も本当こういう風にいろんな人に感謝されるから続いてますね。
うん。ま、僕も多分根本は教えるのは好きなんですよね。
ああ、なるほど。
はい。
ま、ブログ始めた理由もそうなんか自分の考え方とかをなんかこう、ま、広めたいとか、ま、同じようにも減らして欲しいみたいなところから始まってるからうん。
なんかそうだから今までなんか僕いちいち
YouTube飽きてた時期があって
なんかですか
はい。ま、同じような繰り返し日々とかないですけど、
お家にカメラ置いて喋ってで、人と喋ることもなくカメラに向かって喋るだけみたいな。
ま、それなりにそれでお金も稼ぎちゃうし、ま、承人欲求をもたせちゃうから、
ま、ま、ありがたいことに楽なお仕事ではある。ま、当時で言うと、ま、楽な仕事だなとか思いつつでもなんかちょっと飽きてるとこあったんですけど、この片企画始めてからはいろんなとこにお出かきしたりとか話したりとか、
もういろんな人と話すから日々新しい発見もあるし、
こんなに備蓄もってる人いるんだみたい。
人とかいろんな人と会えるからですね。
そうですね。
だから本当にありがくだからそれこそ物減らすのは若いになった方がいいって話。うん。そう。
元も年取ったら気力がなくたくなる。うん。片付けると
そう。で、それでどんどん語ってるのが奥になってどんどん家がゴミやすかしてくって人僕いっぱい来てきて
で僕教えてる僕自身もこれ若い時じゃないとこんなにぴょんぴょン異常して
うん。
特に撮影しながら語ってるからめっちゃエネルギー使うんですよ。
カメラのことも考えないといけないですとか。
うん。うん。
うん。
そう。1
人でもうカメラのアシスタントとかなしで
人でやってるんで、こういう画角とかも全部自分で考えながらやってますし。うん。
だから、ま、これ楽しそう。
おお。楽しいです。本当に
ねえ。生きして
楽しそうです。
あ、本当に今人生で一番楽しいすね。
うん。だってね、好きなことでみんなに
あの感謝されて幸せを書いて。
うん。本当にありがたいことです。うん。
そうなので僕もだからこの企画ちょっと
30代、ま、ちょうど30歳になって今年
31になる。ええ、若く見えるね。うん。
ありがとうございます。なので、
ま、この若いうちに僕も飛び回れる暇だからことを頑張ってやろうというか、私も感謝された。何?何?何?
[笑い]
いや、いや、でもでも姉ちゃんのコメントとか見るとさ。
そうです。そうです。
うん。うん。
ま、たまたまにその自分がやりたかったミニマルライスっていうところと
言うな。言うな。
たまたま密のところがすごい混ってしまってどんどん
ま、やっぱりあの子供悪いんですけどあの僕も蓄とか防災系学ぶ時にめっちゃ
[笑い]
YouTubeとか見たんですけどやっぱ
YouTube
ってあの不安を煽るコンテンツが伸びるんですよ。
例えばいいついつに何回トラックが来ますとか、ま、予言の動画、
ま、実際聞けないじゃんみたいな話なんですけど、
あの、ま、最近もありましたよね。
ましたね。ポンで
本のなんか有名なでしたっけ?
あなたが見た未来だった。
そうだ。
その方が
来なかった。来なかった。来なかった。
でもああいうのって伸びるんですよ。やっぱ人間ってプラスのことよりもそのマイナス要素、ネガティブな情報に引かれるものだからあの防災もそうで何回トラックがいつ来ますみたいなもなんもうずっと見てますよ。
その動画いつ来るねんみたいな話ですけど、やっぱりでもそういう不安を煽る動画だったりとかで不安を煽りつつもそうだからいっぱい備蓄しときましょうみたいな
動画どうしても伸びちゃうから、
ま、多分ルさんの問題で言うとその備えれば備えるほどいっぱい買い込むほど再生回数が伸びちゃうっていう
安心でもう
で本人も
やっぱ備えとくと安心するってとこもあるだろうし
そうですね最近はそんなもう買っては
いないですけどね。
うん。
出してこちょこちょ楽しそうですね。出してこれ出して出して出したら痛い。出したらでも正直て言うと備蓄のことってそんなに喋ることなくなりません途中で。
[笑い]
あ、そうですね。整理頓
あの備蓄とあと整理生頓の
うん。
YouTubeも
はい。一緒にやってます。[笑い]
そうですね。ま、色々雑にあげてやっちゃってるけど、ま、間違いなく立ち君の時が一番飲みますよね。
そうだね。
そう、未蓄チャンネルになってるなと思ったんですけど。
そうですね。
その難しいすよね。だからこれ
YouTuber
としては正しいんですよ。
伸びた伸びたネタをひたすらこするっていう僕に言うと片付けて企画が伸びたみたいな
[笑い]
YouTuberっているんですか?自称
YouTuber
2700人いたら
もYouTuber
って呼べるんですかね?
自です。自称ですよね。
ちょいちょい自称ですよ。
ま、世間一般で言うと
YouTuberあるけど天強として食ってた。底辺
[笑い]
えっと
やっぱそうです。
占だったらすよ。でもあくまであの、ま、主婦をされてる中で守備としてやられてること考えるとこの
2700ってそれじゃ本当にすごくて
あ、そうなんです。
多くの人は本当に100人
1000人どころか100人いかないで
000YouTubeの基準も今500
かだった。500か1000
ちょっと今ですけど、ま、昔は
人行かないと、えっと、報告つかないとか。
今もね、
今もそうですね。
今も線が1
個の横なんですけど、多くの人線行かずに散ってきます。
うん。うん。
しかもそれ9
ヶ月でここまで行ってるから実は
YouTuber
としてはすごい正解の道行ってるんですけど
こと私生活そのミニマルなミニマルな生活したいってことに対して備蓄の動画を出さないと伸びないってことになっちゃってるから難しいですね。
[笑い]
そのしかも備蓄の方面もどっちかと言うとこうどうですか?結構たくさんてる系ですか?
なんか
さ、
ま、割とたくさん備えてる方ではありますね。冷蔵庫。
ま、そうですね。ま、要はなんか
難しい問題ですけど、
ま、ご本人もそういう風にやっぱりたくさんある方向落ち着くみたい。
ま、コナ禍を得てコロナ禍減て
うん。
ちょっと、ま、自連マがそういう冒頭にも話したけど、ちょっと自連マがあったりして、ま、そこも含めてちょっと面白いと思ってさ、
[笑い]
やっぱり
しさんは、あ、ごめんなさい。
その日々みこうやって動画撮った趣味も一緒ってことですか?仕事が趣味って感じですか?あ
あ、でも今仕事趣味って言ってます。
ああ、そうそうそうだもん。
うん。
僕ミニマリストになった理由は働きたくないからてのは結構あったんですけど。うん。
とにかくミニマムに暮らして僕もフリタジとか月
6万生活しました。
うん。
で、もう週3
だけバイトしてで、あと残りの週
はあものんびり食らってみたいな実際それやってたし、
ま、それをやってたことによって時間が浮いたからこのミニマリストの発信ができて
結果仕事になったっていう。
だから、あの、自分で仕事作りたい人ほどミニマムに生活費下げて暮らせっていうのは言ってるんですけど、ま、
20生きるのに20万円必要な人と6
枚で済む人だったら絶対6
枚で済む人の方が
その成功の確率高いじゃないですか。
うん。うん。
ね、20万の人だったら20
万円分ね、ちゃんと仕事しないとやっていけないから副業の時間とか作れないけど、
僕はもう週月6万、週3
バイトで巻かてたから、
もう週4
は好きな時間に回ったりとか、ま、だから、
あの、自分で仕事作りたい人ほどとにかく生活費下げてミニマムらせって話をしてるんですけど、
なんか欲が出てきちゃうんですけど、なんかいい車乗りたいとか
それはどうやって押し殺してるんですか?あ、押し
[笑い]
なんかもうあのね、確かに
乗りたいとかあるじゃないですか、男って。
はい。
そういうのがもう
そういうの全くない。最初からない感じですか?
なんかの広いですみたいとか生活じゃなくていうのはもうえっとありました。
10代はありました。
ああ、10代は。
その実際僕大学に行きたくて
でとにかく慶王行ったらかっこいいし
なんかモてそうだし
で行ったら、ま、大企業就職できて年収も高くなるだろうみたいな。
で、僕のも結構もう本当にお家広くて欲しいもの何でも買ってもらえる環境だったからやっぱりお金稼いでいっぱいものがあるほど幸せっていう風に思ったんで
も2
年間浪人認したんですけど、ま、結果フリーターになってですよね。二ロし上げ大学行ってないっていう
感じですけど成功してるからね結果良かったんですけど。
うん。
そうすね。だから本当に物減らし始めてから逆に欲しいものに満たされるようになったというかあ。
ま、もちろんこういう生活してたらお金も溜まるし時間もたまるし
うん。ま、なんか旅行に行くとか、
ま、僕もなんか物の数は少ないんだけど、ま、買う、買う、なんか量よりつって
1個1個いいものは持ってるから。
あ、そうですよね。そうやっておっしゃって。
だから買う時は買ってるからなんかなんかそういう意味ではちゃんと物は満たせてるし数は少ないけどうん。うん。
で、ま、もっと言うとなんかも僕は物欲よりも経験欲への投資にお金使いたいというの方があって、ま、まか僕例えば目の視力回復つってやってるんですけど、ま、レーシックの違うバージョンあ
とか私立強制とか
うん。
脱毛とか肌量とか多分肉体改造はもう
2300万ぐらい。
へえ。
トータルすると
100万、70万、
2脱満もそうすね。うん。
ま、多分そんぐらい使ってたりとか、ま、旅行に行くとかうん。うん。
なんかそうものじゃないところ形ない経験自己投資みたいな。
うん。
あ、そう。
自分投に対する欲求はありました。なんかこう今の仕事頑張って脱毛行きたい、私強制したいとかそこはモチベーションになってたかな。
うん。
とか多分この動画出してる時にはもう言ってるんですけど、ま、最近テスラっていう車は買って
あ、そうなんですか。1
つ知らないです。まだ
そう。多分この時はYouTube
でも言ってるんですけど。
すごい。
そう。僕、あの、車の免許も実は
29歳まで持ってなくて
うん。
で、えっと、片付企画を始めて結構素大ゴミを運ぶシーンが多かったりとか、あ、
結構地方に行くとやっぱ車の足ちょっと欲しいところがあったりして、
うん。
片付け企画初めてようやく免許通いで取って
で、ま、YouTube
のために免許取ったんですけどました。本で
あ、ありがとうございます。
ちょうど本まそう。あの、
本で持ってるんですよ、実は。今日でも車はいるんだ。
これです。
これです。えっと、
これ呼びました。持ってます。持ってます。
入ってます。
やって走ってたもんね。
ありがとうございます。
買わなきゃって[笑い]
買ってくださってで実はこの本でえっといですよ。
[笑い]
で、この本って実は2018
年に書いた本で7年前の本なんですけど、
この時には僕免許取った後、ま、必要ないって書いてたし、取ってないって話したんですけど、過質修正して
7年前にうん。うん。
ま、撮影企画で使うなって免許ってみたい話をここに書いてるんですけど。
あ、
で、免許取った先に最近なんかあのなんかマイナンバーカードにあの免許を一体化できるようになったりとか、
ま、最近はそのなんか免許いらないって言ってた
年前よりももうカシアがめっちゃ増えてたから
うん。
なんか前ってこんなカシアなかったから、ま、免許取ってもそんなに連タカー使わないといけないとかちょっと面倒じゃないですか?
うん。カシアって今結構簡単にアプリ
1発で借りたりするから、
ま、地方に行っても結構カシアあるし、
ま、車所有しなくてもカシアとかでタイムズカーシアだったら別額
800円とか払えば、
ま、あとは15分220
円とかガソリンコミとか結構乗れるんで
うん。
なんか、ま、乗りそういうなんか試合が増えたとかもあるし、今僕
1番興味あるのが自動運転なんですよ。
ああ、あります。あります。
で、僕買った車がテスラっていう、ま、一応世界で
1番売れてる車で
はい。はい。はい。
最近よく見ますね。テスラ増えましたよね。
増えました。
へ、
あの、
結構日本、今結構世界的に日本でもテスラめっちゃ売れてるみたいなデータがあったりとかま
うん。
で、僕1
番そのテスラ買った理由なんですけど、多分もう
年中に自動運転来ると思ってます。
多分来ます。もう絶んですよ。絶対来ます。
はい。えっと、もう
はい。
でも結構今アメリカとか近場だと韓国とかでももう始まってたりしてで日本人とかもありますもんね。アメリカとかタクシー。
あ、まさにそうです。えっとアメリカだとウイモっていう
ドの[笑い]
車好きですね。はい。でもなんかウイモっていう
Google参加のあのAI
企業のその自動運転クシーとかあとま、テスラもロボタクシーって言ってもうテスラのモデル
Y
って車がそんま無人のタクシーになってたりとか
うん。で、僕の買った理由なんですけど、
番はそのもう自動運転で勝手に車が走ってる間に僕が仕事したりとか、もうリス寝たりとか
して、で、起きた時にはなんかもう次の片現場についててで不要品も車に詰めて捨てるみたいな。
車で生活して
で、かつそれが自動運転で移動中は寝たり仕事したりって言ってなんか僕の今の
1番の理想のライフスタイル。
へえ。そう。
そっていうのがなんかも結構割と現実身を帯びてきたから、ま、このタイミングだったら車買っていいなと思って。
うん。
ちなみに何色方?
白、白です。それなんだ?[笑い]
なんとなくなんとなくそん黒かな?黒
迷ったんですけど、しかもでシートも白なんで車内真っ白です。
へえ。
なんかでも白だといいね。
あ、そうなの?[笑い]
何がいいんすか?
あの、マイナーっていうか、あの、一般的なやつだから汚れないし。
ああ、
それにしなくてもいいし。
ま、白、ま、オですね。ま、白と黒が一番売れてる車だから。ああ、いう、
黒と汚れが目立つんだわ。
まだ黒目立ちます。
はい。
黒はまあ、ま、僕が黒いんでね。
[笑い]
はい。あとテスラは車内があの、ま、車界のミニマリストって言われてても車内何もないです。へえ。
そうなんだ。もうハンドルとタブレットしかないで
なんかよくあるエアコンの
なんかこう温度調整物理ボタンとか一切なくて
え、
エアコンついてないんです。
エアコンはついてるんですけどなんかでしょ?ひょっとしたら
えっとまとにかく車内がもうめっちゃシンプルなんですよ。
液晶がある感じですか?
もう液晶タブレットとハンドルだけて
押してくんだ。設定なんでしょうかね。
そうです。
だからもう物理ボタンがないから全部タブレットでエアコンの温度とか
やだね。誰乗れない。ブレーキこれなん?
[笑い]
ああ、そうです。
なんか今僕です。
僕です。
あのシフトレバーないです。
へえ。
シフトレバーと
あとなんか方向指示機がない。
ええ、どうやって方向するんですか?
えっと、ハンドル上にボタンがある。
すごい
とかもあったりするので、ま、なんかそういう風にもう車内もミニマルって感じで、ま、それも引かれてちょっと乗りたいなってのあったんですけど、一緒ですね。うん。
はい。
車もミニマルっていうそういうの買ってるんですけど。へ。
ま、だからどうだろうな。この動画がいつ公開されてるかわかんないけどワンチャン自動運って始まったりするんじゃないか。
だったらおめでとうですね。
そうですね。この予言が当たってたらいいな。
[笑い]
うん。うん。
いや、僕半年以内にワンチャン来るんじゃないかなと思う。
ま、結構よく行くよ。結構もうあの東京の方だったらその自動運転のテストカーと走ってる。
あ、ふんふんふん。
そうみたいなね。車買ったりしましたね。本当片付け企画、片付け企画始めて車買うとも思ってなかったし。
そうですよね。車買わない人から持たないと思っ
持たない人から買った。どんどん増えてくんじゃない
[笑い]
ね。マイフォー買ったりする。
逆になんかどんどんそれは面白いね。したからなんかあのインタビューに行きたい私どうなるかね。僕もわかんないですからね。
[笑い]
もういいですか?
うん。
でもなんか1
つは結構なんか押し形っていうの教えるってことだから
つ車買った理由として大きいのあと車買ったら車のこと教えてるなっていうのが
1つ大きいですね。最近結構僕なんか
YouTube
の生配信とかで車のこと聞かれたら結構具体的に答えれてるんですけど。
ま、腹落ちしてるというか、ま、だから例えばじゃ、車手放すかどうかとか聞いた時に、あとそれこそも来日車売るんですけど、僕実はもう
2台目なんですよ。
ええ、
僕車買って1年ではい。
どんどん増えてるじゃん。
携帯、携帯みたい。携帯。
あ、でもそう1
年で買い替えたんですよ、僕。えっと、1
年車年だ。
すごい
車最初認定中古っていう中古で買ってで
代目は新車で買ったんですけど、ま、だから
台目を売ったりとか、ま、売る時のこともだからも分かるし
すご
なんかそれ一通り経験しとけば、ま、このコーチングとかでも、ま、教えれるは大事ですね。
代目もテスラですか?2
代目もテスラでもうテスラからテスラに乗り換えてっていう。
まあ、でもテスラとかもでも行く先は多分もうまさにテスラとかのいう自動運転が進んだ車もいらないんですよね。
はい。
だって運転だったら、えっと、それこそタクシー台とかが
1/5とか下手すると1/10
になるみたいな話があったりして、
あ、
ま、だから今初乗り
500円700円するのがもう100
円とか200
円くらいなるみたいなのってなったらもうじゃあ本当にタクシーでいいよねとかそもそもタクシーが無人で走るんだったら
うん。
ま、パーソナルの空間だからね。
うん。うん。
その、ま、自価要者持つメリットってじゃあ、ま、タクシーでもいいんだけど、なんか僕タクシー運転士さんと話すのあんま好きじゃなかったりするんですけど
とか
じゃあ車の中で
Zoom
の会議するとかなった時に会議たくないとかあるから
なんか自価用者持つメリットってパーソナル空間っていうの
つあると思うんですけど、もうこれが無人タクシーとかで価格も落ちて無人になるんだったらもう車持たなくていいすよね。
もう乗りたくなったらね、数百円で呼んでっていうのが簡単できるから、
ま、なんかそういう意味でもなんか今その人間が運転するとか車を所有するってなんか今しかできないなっていうのなんか
うん。
あってなんか割ともう5年後10
年後に多くの人と車持たなくなってんだろうなっていうのが
うん。
ま、今も川シ屋とか住んでるからそうですけどうん。
なんか今結構、ま、それこそもっとるとガソリン車と電気事みたいなとか色々なんかきな気がするから、
ま、だからちょっと買ったというか、今しか体験できないなって意味でもう
買いましたね。
へえ。こに何買ったんですか?
[笑い]
いや、でもそれくらいですよ。
インタビューがすげ。
買いたい。欲しい。
なんかしさんが逆に買ったもの買いたい。
買ったもの買ったもの見たい。[笑い]
さんが選び抜いたものに出してもらったら何を買ったのかなって。
買ったものか。いや、もう服もしばらく買ってないしな。あ
あ、
靴とか。
靴ももうボロなんかボロっし。
しかも前か同じの買い直しですよ。うん。
全く同じの買ってるから。
そうですよね。
スーツも同じやつ。靴下はどこの?
靴下はえっと
決まってるんですか?
なんかレイシャルっていうブランドのなんかそのメリノウールっていう素材があってかないとする。
はい。[笑い]
大丈夫。出しやばい。長くなっちゃった。
ちょっと一旦長くなっちゃいそうな。ちょっと一旦ここではい。切っちゃうんですけど。
[笑い]
というので、ま、そうですね。
だから僕本当に片付け企画始めてなんか車の免許取ったり買ったりなんか本当に
自分が今までやらなかったことをやってるから
そう意味でも楽しいすね。う
ん。二川も抜けてるね。
うん。
あ、でもほ
本当にそうすね。
[笑い]
なんかいいこと言ようとしている。
お様で片付きとか始めて本当にかとか向けたと思います。
ということで、あの、お寿司もありがとうございます。ごち様です。
こちらありがとうございます。
ありがとうね。なんかめっちゃ話がだからいい感じにとかもしかして
8ついてます。もしか
ついてません。すいません。逆ですけど。
[笑い]
すいません。すいません。
すいません。ゆ、バスタオルってあります?
あ、バスタオルありますね。あ、すごいません。えっと、フェイスタオルです。
バスタオルてバスタっちゃいけないんだよ。
もいけない。もっとけない。バスタウないよ。
1番の話ですか?
うん。[笑い]
バスタウドは1
番持っちゃいけないですよね。
そうですね。なんかそれ聞いた。バスタオルは持っちゃいけない。
[笑い]
バスタは本当持っちゃいけないっていうよね。
あ、洗う時大変な。
え、でもこれ結構ミニマイクも入っちゃ。
はい。ちょっとこれ編集で順番入れ替えてください。こ
[笑い]
すいません。
あの、バスタオル持っちゃい話だと思うんですけど、あの、ミニマリストのなんかこう王道テクニックでバスタオルをフェイスタオルにするっていうのがあって、
ま、まさに選択する時とか選択感想重ばるし、保管するのもスペース取るから、
ま、フェイスタオルとか最近だったらあのスモールバスタオルみたいなちっちゃいサイズのバスタオルとか結構でもミニマリストに関係なく結構最近どんどんタオルをちっちゃくしていこうっていう、ま、なんか流行ってる気がしますし、多分そういう商品もいっぱいあると売れてる。
うん。
最近なんか同居方って言った時もあったもんなとかあったから。
なんかやっぱりバスタオールってやっぱりもう過剰なもの。ま、
もちろんね、なんかホテルとかにある復火のやつとかね、たまに使うとあ、なんか贅沢だなっていう気持ちはまさに今ホテル止まってるんであるんですけどうん。うん。うん。
でも日常生活においてバスタオルって、ま、特に女性の方とかのよ紙が長くないカは
うん。
いらないですね。
ま、コンパクトなタオル、フェイスタオルとかで十分
けるから。そう、物だらけだよね。
そうするとバスマットもいらないんですか?
あ、バスマット僕持ってないです。
あの、結構な物を減らすっていうのは結構ミニマリストの方がやってると思うんで。
例えばキッチンマットとかトイレマットとか
で例えばトイレマットとかってじゃ両漏れを防ぐために置いてると思うんですけどでも結局そのねトイレマット自体が量ついてるわけだからこれ
掃除するやです。
そうだそう。そうです。
直接ばいいですよね。これとキッチンマットも一緒です。油飛びが飛び散るからとかっていう理由で置いてる人多いと思うんですけど、ま、これも結局油汚れがそこに染みついてるわけだから。
うん。
ま、は、登場後回しにしてるっていうなんか衛生面の観点でも僕はマットない方がいいなっていうのは
思います。
トイレマットとキッチンマットはなくしました。いらないのってカバーじゃない?
ティッシュカバーティッシュカバーはいらない。
カバーはない。いらんでしょ?
あれいらないよね。持ってんの?
持ってる。[笑い]
持ってるか?
本当そう。ティッシュカバーとかティッシュなんかね、結構頻繁に交換するからカバー変えるのめんどくさいし。い
しかもよくあるのがあの箱型じゃないティッシュとかを大体袋型ですね。袋型のティッシュをカバーしてでティッシュの残量が減ると小さくペシャンプへっていうすごい見つぼらしいんですよね。もない。
[笑い]
で、1
番いいのはもう、えっと、パッケージがシンプルなものをそんま買って、そんま置くっていう。うん。うん。
うん。
そうですね。
何も繁殖しないし。そうです。やりなさい。
そうなんです。理論だけ言うけど行動には映してない。
正解です。
妹さんですけど。
はい。
片けない。けない。
いや、でもそうなんです。そういう風にやっぱ布の物とかって特にみんななんかあのそういう風にカバーしたりとかしいたりとかラグとかもそうすね。
極力、ま、やっぱない方が掃除選択も楽だし。
うん。
もう僕なんか家カーテンないですから。うん。あ、そうですね。
カーテンとかもやっぱり
すりガラスですか?
すりガラス風にするシート貼った。
ああ、そう。シートあるんですね。
で、目隠ししたりとか。ま、カーテンどうしても日光の問題一緒の人とかだったら、ま、例えばロールスクリーンにするとか。うん。うん。
でもシブさんにストーカーが現れて
電気がついてる。家にいるわってなっちゃったら
引っ越しますよ。僕もいつでも引っ越せる。
[笑い]
あ、僕ら
1個です。
車1個で直夜逃げできるんで。
うん。
ストーカーに家知られてる状態ないから。
そうですね。
引っ越しますね。し、僕はでもそんくらいもう少ないから場所に縛らなくていいんですよ。
ああ、
スーツケース1
個できる。そうなんかほぼほぼね。
虎ラさんみたいな。
虎ラさん。
車があるからもう何でもある。車あるとね。
それなんですよ。
実はミニマリズムの発症って実はあのバンライフって言われるようななんか車で生活人たちとかタイニーハウスっていうその小屋暮らしみたいな
なんかそういうもの少ない人が車で生活するとかそう車で生活するのも物ものが少なくていきないじゃないですか
で僕なんか10
代の頃に書いたやりたいことリストの中になんか車で生活するっていうのがあったりして
うん。
ま、なんかいつかやりたいなと思ってたんですけど、まあでも別に生活には必要ないしってとことで多い。
でも渋さんのニーズを叶えるのはキャンピングカーピングカーがいい。
そうだから
止まれるもん。そのままで
止まってそのまま
な話あのね、住民表
そうなんだ。もう実家じゃないか。
[笑い]
ああ、そうすね。
で、車で行ってちょっとそこの駐車場行きっときますって言ってそこでで翌日おはようございますて言ってまた
やっていただければ
でも今結構そういう生活してます。
あの車中泊テスラは実はキャンプモードっていうのがあって車中泊するように電気自動車なんでエアコンっぱなしで寝れるんですよ。
へえ。え、
だから実はガソリン車より、ま、車中泊は絶対にガソリンより電気車は良くて、
しかもアイドリングしても音があのガソリンエンジンがない。
うん。
もう真夜中エアコンっすごい静かだし、
めっちゃ空調くんで、ま、僕だから
あの、結構この片付企画とかでもちょいちょいで実は車中泊しながら語片
YouTube
とかあるんですよ、ちょいちょい。
へえ。
そうなので、ま、ホテル台も浮いてますね。
うん。
そう。だから僕
寝てすらも実は後ろがフルフラットになるから
寝れます。
全然寝れます。
カプセルホテルって言われたりするぐらい。あ、
おい、面白さん。テスできてほしい。
ああ、そうっすね。ちょっと待って。第
[笑い]
またお会いできると思って。
あ、でも一応もうお会いできできるかなってもすぐに会っちゃうん。ちょっともう終ったから。
[笑い]
あ、でも今後はですね、あの、片付けた人はリバウンドしてないかとか、どういう生活してるかっていうその、その人の
リバウンドしてそう、その学やばいね。
[笑い]
トイレペーパー増えて
でもやっぱしさんならダイエダイエットのコーチングもできそう。
ああ。あ、まあ、[笑い]
何いっぱいやって結局ダイエットの
ダイエットも語ってもあの、ま、本質は一緒で結局や
なんか体の脂肪を捨てるってこと。そうだからいい窓口があり、引き出しありそう。
はい。まあ、なんかでも極論言うと物減らすのとダ似てて、
ま、物家せたかったもの減らせばいいし、ダイエットしたよ食べなきゃいいですよね。
シンプルに
ていう、ま、そのせ、消費カロリーよりも摂取カロリーが、ま、上回らなければいいっていう、ま、シンプルな理屈だから
はい。っていうね、ま、そういうね、そう、タオルの話とかちょっとうまく使ってください。
[笑い]
すいません。すいません。
いや、僕としてはすごいで長々お邪魔してすいません。楽しい。
面白い
という感じでおしいごちそうさでした。ありがとうございます。
こちさ、ちょっと